Trey and Kenny is the president of the
Turning Point Oakland activism Hub and
she joins us tonight Chad thank you so
much for coming on so if I mean just to
ask the obvious question if you don't
have an English language driver's manual
then people who speak English can't
study for the driving test is that right
exactly
how to drive if we can't even
thank you so much for making it because
it's it's small things like this that
really tell you what's happening to the
country but I was struck with a total
lack of sympathy that you got from the
woman at the DMV when she didn't seem
that interested in the fact you couldn't
read a driver's manual in your own
country at all no she did not care and
in fact she told me to stop filming she
didn't seem like she didn't really want
people to know there was no handbooks in
English anymore this is a public place
we should be allowed to film and talk
about this
um especially because we're all trying
to learn to drive and
we can't because we can't read the
manuals well of course and it's your
country and this is the DMV these people
work for you uh yeah and last question I
just want to make sure this is exactly
correct factually they didn't have an
English language driver's manual for
over a month in the purportedly richest
state in the country they just couldn't
get around to printing it or something a
whole month an entire month
yeah unbelievable
Cheyenne Kenny I appreciate your coming
on and telling that story and for
documenting it thank you thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight